- Hiccup!
Hiccuping!
Fire burps!
Ahh!
- Los Angeles is know for
its amazing Asian cuisine,
and I'm gonna take the other
Try Guys on a trip around town
to some surprise locations,
where they're gonna try
some extreme Asian dishes.
- Aww.
- I don't want that.
- What?
It's gonna get intense!
- Eugene's torturing us.
- I'm gonna try to eat as
little food as possible.
You know why?
'Cause I got a fucked up tongue.
Secret's out, everybody.
I got geographic tongue.
- I feel like the three dishes I've chosen
cover everything from
creepy to slimy to spicy.
- Try Guys Feast Mode Asian Food
Extreme Adventure Something!
(upbeat music)
- Alright, so the first
restaurant I'm going to
is this awesome place called Typhoon.
It's a Pan-Asian fusion restaurant.
You're gonna be eating bugs.
- What?
- What kind of bugs?
'Cause lobsters are bugs.
(bell dings)
- Keith's arm is on me.
It's just you're--
- It's only on you, because
your elbow's in my stomach!
- Because it's a tight backseat,
because we're in your stupid car.
- Kids!
- [Zach] What?
(upbeat music)
- Hi, my name is Brian Vidor,
and I am the owner of Typhoon,
here at the Santa Monica Airport.
- So you were working in Asia,
you moved over here and opened Typhoon.
- Yeah.
- You were inspired by
some of the different
snacks and street foods in Asia.
- Street foods, you got it, yes.
- Yeah.
- The crickets were in
Taipei Beer Gardens,
and the silkworm pupas are from Thailand.
We're getting more and more
people coming here for the bugs.
They taste pretty good.
- [Eugene] So these are
Taiwanese-Style Crickets?
- I had a lizard growing
up who ate crickets.
They looked just like this.
- That's a big old plate of bugs!
- You wanna feed each other?
- Sure.
(upbeat music)
- Mmm.
- Oh no, it's great.
- It's almost like eating the
skin off of fried chicken.
- I got a leg in the back
of my throat for a second.
- They keep jumping onto my chopsticks.
- Extremeness, I'm gonna say, like one.
It's not that extreme.
- No, I would eat this as a snack.
- Bugs are beautiful.
- [Together] Woah!
- [Ned] They look like
little chicken nuggets.
- I don't know if they
look like chicken nuggets.
They look like bugs.
- Ribbed for her pleasure.
- Oh, please.
- So, these are really popular
in a lot of Asian countries,
especially in Korea, where
we call them Beondegi.
- Butt-diggy.
(upbeat music)
- Oh, no!
- Huh, didn't expect that.
- Oh!
- Soft.
- Oh, it just bursts.
(upbeat music)
- It just tastes a lot like corn.
- Tasty, wet hay.
- Oh, I could see a horse
just going to town on this.
(horse neighing)
- And these are worm babies.
- Holy fuck, you can kinda see through it.
Oh God, why?
Why?
- It's not the most pleasant experience.
- Bugs overall, sort of extreme.
Decently tasty and always
looks like a plate of bugs.
- [Ned] Cut to the car!
♫ I ate too many bugs
♫ Oh, Lord, I ate too many bugs ♫
- So we left the bug
place, what's next, Eugene?
- We're doing a water
creature of some sort.
- Okay.
- Like a lobster?
I love lobsters.
- Think more sucking.
- Some sort of blow job fish?
- We are going to eat live octopus.
- Oh!
- You guys, why was the octopus laughing?
- Why?
- 'Cause he had ten-tickles.
(laughter)
Let's go eat one.
- Alright guys, we are here in Koreatown,
at Wassada Restaurant,
and in a lot of Korean
and Japanese cuisine,
things are so fresh, they're
still basically alive.
- [Keith] This looks crazy.
- So sea urchin, or
uni, is quite expensive.
- [Keith] It's a delicacy, right?
- [Eugene] Yeah, it's a delicacy.
- Is that its butt?
- It looks like the top
of a good, sexy starfish.
You know, some starfish look shitty.
- Eat it.
- Alright.
What was that?
- Woah, that's amazing.
- It's like, buttery.
- I don't know what I just tasted.
- Where's the butter coming from?
- It's really complicated.
It kinda tastes like if melon was a meat.
- It's what lobsters' blood tastes like.
- I like to call this the
foie gras of the ocean.
- Who would have thought there'd be
something so good inside
this coffee straw coconut?
- Does anyone have bread?
- Oh, no!
- Oh, no.
- There goes that shirt.
Do you have anything
to get this stain out?
The video can wait, okay?
I don't want this to stain.
- [Eugene] And the best part
is, is you can just, like--
- Oh, a toothpick!
- I mean, it's hardcore, it's not extreme.
- But it is an animal and
we are eating its gonads.
- Alright.
- [Eugene] One of my
favorite dishes, Sannakji,
which is what we call live octopus.
It's recently alive octopus.
- [Ned] Does it move?
- [Eugene] It moves.
This is especially prevalent
in Korea and Japan.
- Oh!
- That's its eyeball?
- [Keith] Ah, look you got one!
(gagging impression)
- [Eugene] Oh, it won't let go.
- Oh, that feels so weird.
- Oh, I don't want to do it.
- And, go!
Chew, chew.
- Oh, no.
Oh, no!
- [Ned] Oh, Zach.
No, Zach, no!
- [Keith] Don't die!
- Is it moving?
- No!
I don't know, actually.
- My wife loves me.
- Oh, it's stuck in my throat.
- Oh, ow.
- It's stuck to the top of my mouth!
- It wouldn't let go of my lip.
- How's it taste?
- It's really chewy.
- It's like seafood gum.
- It's actually delicious.
- I mean, you can't get
rawer than this, right?
- No, this is the freshest
food I've ever had.
- This is the most extreme
thing I've ever eaten.
- I'm afraid to swallow this big one.
- [Eugene] You guys good with
one more restaurant, right?
- I feel like I feel it trying
to grab onto my intestines.
- I know!
I think it's like trying to work
its way back up my esophagus.
- I'm still eating it.
(laughter)
- [Zach] What?
- So we had bugs.
- [Zach] We had bugs.
- We had sea creatures.
- [Zach] Yeah.
- And now we're gonna do
something pretty tame.
You know?
Something pretty tame for the finale.
- Okay.
- Just the spiciest dish in Los Angeles.
- Eugene, my tongue's fucked up.
- So, we're going to a Thai
restaurant called Jitlada.
- [Ned] Oh, I love Jitlada!
- We know that you guys have something
called 'The Dynamite Challenge.'
- Yes, you guys should try.
It's really good and spicy.
- [Keith] How spicy are we talking?
- [Waitress] One to ten?
- [Zach] Yeah, ten being the biggest.
- [Waitress] Ten.
- I'm nervous.
I'm anxious.
- We both love spicy food.
I basically grew up on spicy food.
- I've chosen a piece that
like, has no visible spice.
- Yeah, me too.
- I'll put more spice on,
I'll put more spice on.
- [Eugene] And just before you guys start,
keep the screaming to a minimum.
- Yeah, Eugene, we'll keep
our screaming to a minimum.
- You wanna just stick the
whole thing in our mouths?
- Shouldn't we?
- Okay, ready?
- [Eugene] Go!
(suspenseful music)
- Oh, God.
(clearing throat)
Oh!
- Oh, my God.
- Fuck me, fuck me, fuck me.
- Keith, are you okay?
- Nuh-uh.
- [Zach] Oh, no!
(gagging noise)
- I think I'm gonna vomit.
- Oh, I'm already farting.
- Oh!
- There's like a fountain of saliva--
- There's a --
- Oh!
Delicious flavor.
(blowing nose)
- Ow, it's getting worse, it's getting--
- The most preposterous
dish in Los Angeles.
- I'm giving cunnilingus
to a piece of cucumber.
That's how much pain I'm in.
- Am I crying?
Am I sweating?
- They cure all diseases.
It cures Eugene.
(laughter)
If I eat them, maybe I
will be cured as well.
Dear, Jitlada.
Your 'Dynamite Challenge'
was the last stop
in our Extreme Asian Food Tour.
We regret everything, but we love you!
I can't stop burping, Ned.
Farting, Zach.
Crying, Eugene.
Dying, Keith.
Love, The Try Guys.
♫ I can feel the fire ♫
- This was just the battle.
The war will be waged
on my toilet all night.
It's a good thing my wife's out of town.
- Keith, how about I
find Italian foods next?
I'm Italian.
Italians have very interesting
cuisine, like pasta.
(car door slams)
Oh, my friends left.